en el último vídeo preparamos todo para
definir la aproximación cuadrática de
una función y a esta aproximación la
hemos llamado q qué es una función
verdad y de hecho esta es la
aproximación de una función arbitraria a
la cual hemos llamado f he visto nada
más así esta fórmula se veje servía para
brillante y en realidad si te das cuenta
tenemos seis términos tenemos seis
términos distintos aunque esencialmente
los primeros tres los hemos tomado de la
aproximación lineal verdad de la línea
lización local de la función y lo
escribimos de forma abstracta en
realidad verdad y los siguientes tres
verdad los siguientes tres términos son
son los términos cuadra ticos pero los
modificamos para que no hubiera ningún
problema al evaluar en el punto x 0 y es
cero por eso es que en lugar de x
cuadrada aparece x menos x0 al cuadrado
verdad aquí por ejemplo en vez de poner
x porque pusimos x menos x 0 por ye
menos de 0 y aquí en lugar de ye
cuadrada pusimos ya menos de cero al
cuadrado y todo esto es para que al
evaluar en x 0
estos términos se anulen y al final
tengamos que la función que coincide con
la función f en el punto alrededor del
cual estamos aproximando y la pregunta
es cómo podríamos proponer a los
términos a b y c verdad como proponer a
estos coeficientes para que que aproxime
muy bien a la función f muy bien
entonces esto en fórmula significa lo
siguiente en realidad lo que nosotros
buscamos lo que nosotros queremos verdad
es que la segunda derivada de la función
q con respecto digamos a la variable x
ambas veces verdad todo esto tiene que
ir evaluado en el punto que nos interesa
x0 y es cero verdad esto queremos que
coincida con la segunda derivada de
nuestra función f con respecto a x ambas
veces y evaluadas nuevamente en el mismo
punto x0 de cero esta es nuestra idea de
que aproxime muy bien a la función que
coincida en sus segundas derivadas
parciales y por supuesto podríamos
pensar no sólo en esta segunda derivada
podríamos pensar en la segunda derivada
de cv con respecto
digamos primero con respecto a x y luego
con respecto a y otra vez evaluada en el
punto x 0 10/0 verdad y esto queremos
que coincida con la segunda derivada de
f con respecto de x y con respecto de
después
evaluada en el punto también x 0 10/0 y
como recordarás en un principio las
digamos al invertir el orden de las
derivadas parciales podríamos podría
tener valores distintos verdad podríamos
tener otros valores pero típicamente
para las funciones que estamos
considerando siempre la segunda derivada
con respecto de x y luego con respecto
de y coincide con la segunda derivada
primero con respecto de ye y luego con
respecto de x verdad esto es para la
mayor la digamos para la mayoría de las
funciones con las que vamos a estar
trabajando da lo mismo en qué orden
estamos derivando entonces
solo eso fue un recordatorio vamos a
eliminarlo de aquí por un por ahora ok y
finalmente entonces como coinciden las
las dos digamos derivadas parciales
cruzadas boots verdad como coinciden
entonces pues puedo dar lo mismo poner
primero respecto de de xy luego respecto
de y al revés pero también queremos que
la segunda derivada de q con respecto de
ambas veces evaluada en el punto
nuevamente que nos interesa que era x 0
y es cero coincide también con la
segunda derivada de f con respecto a y
ambas veces en el punto x 0 10/0 bien
entonces queremos que en resumen
queremos que todas las derivadas
parciales de segundo orden de cv
coincidan con las derivadas parciales de
f muy bien entonces vamos a hacer que
vamos a buscar a y b y c para que es la
derivada con respecto de que coincida
con las derivadas respecto de efe ambas
de segundo orden
vamos a vamos a eliminar digamos todo
esto vamos a eliminar todo esto para
hacernos espacio muy bien quizás no hay
que olvidar que estamos evaluando en el
punto que nos interesa verdad pero vamos
a omitir lo por un momento muy bien
entonces quizás debería también quitar
esto para tener espacio
muy bien entonces vamos a empezar a
derivar para lo cual necesitamos
fijarnos en nuestra función original
verdad o más bien la función q que
habíamos propuesto y esto será igual a
derivar con respecto de x la derivada de
q con respecto de x verdad entonces si
derivamos esta expresión primero
derivamos esta que es una constante
entonces la derivada es cero verdad
quizás vamos a quitar esa línea para que
quede más claro y ahora si derivamos
esta expresión en realidad vemos que es
lineal con respecto de x y esto es una
constante entonces en realidad sólo nos
quedamos con esta constante que es la
derivada de f con respecto de x evaluada
en el punto x 0 y es cero
y luego derivamos este término que si
nos damos cuenta en realidad no hay
ninguna equis así que tendremos cero
verdad bueno vamos a quitar esto
entonces tendremos ser y luego ahora
vamos a derivar este siguiente término
verdad aquí tendríamos esta constante a
por la derivada de x x 0 al cuadrado
entonces aquí tendremos dos veces a
verdad por digamos pensemos la regla de
la cadena es dos veces a por x menos x 0
- x 0 verdad ahí lo tenemos esta es la
derivada de este término y ahora en este
siguiente término tenemos que es lineal
en x verdad pensamos ahí como una
constante entonces sería b por la
constante que menos de 0 x es la
derivada de esto que es uno verdad
entonces simplemente vamos a tener b
de menos de cero
de cero y finalmente nos damos cuenta
que esto solo depende de ella así que al
derivar con respecto de x nos da 0
verdad entonces simplemente tenemos que
esto es la primera derivada de q con
respecto de x y eso es lo que hay que
derivar con respecto de x entonces si
derivamos esto bueno por supuesto
tenemos 0 la derivada de esto es 0
porque es una constante tenemos cero y
ahora derivamos esto con respecto de x y
simplemente nos da 2a verdad y si ahora
derivamos esto con respecto de x pues
nos da 0 porque aquí no hay ningún
término que dependa de x entonces
nuestra segunda derivada de q con
respecto de x ambas veces en el punto x
0 y 0 es justamente 2a pero no olvidemos
que es lo que nosotros queremos queremos
que esta segunda derivada coincida con
la segunda derivada de f verdad entonces
lo que queremos es que esto sea igual es
que esto sea igual a la segunda derivada
de f con respecto de x ambas
por supuesto quizás debería notarlo en
la anotación simplificada esto es la
segunda derivada de x evaluada en el
punto x 0,70 muy bien entonces lo único
que tenemos que hacer es despejar quien
tendría que ser a verdad porque si hay
queremos que 2a sea esta segunda
derivada quiere decir que a es un medio
de la segunda derivada de f con respecto
de x ambas veces evaluado en el punto x
0 10/0 muy bien entonces ya tenemos
quien tiene que ser a y esencialmente
está relacionado con la segunda derivada
de verdad esto es el valor de a muy bien
entonces ahora lo que quiero es calcular
la segunda derivada de q con respecto de
x y luego con respecto de y verdad
entonces quizás vamos a borrar esto de
aquí
esto de aquí muy bien y vamos a poner lo
que queremos vamos a hacerlo todo encima
do para no estar gastando más espacio
entonces vamos a derivar primero
respecto de xy luego respecto de yo
quizás valdría la pena primero derivar
esnal sí sí está bien vamos a hacer en
este orden verdad entonces esto de aquí
es lo que ya era la derivada con
respecto de x así que ahora vamos a
derivar con respecto de ya no con
respecto de x verdad entonces derivamos
con respecto de ye muy bien entonces si
derivamos con respecto de otra vez esto
es 0 la derivada de esto es 0 porque es
una constante esto es 0
aquí no hay términos que dependan de
verdad entonces aquí la derivada será
cero así que sólo tenemos este término
dependiente de g así que su derivada
será simplemente ve muy bien así que
ahora tendremos que la derivada no será
2a sino que será
y esto no será 2a va a ser b y ahora
recordemos a quien queremos que sea
igual esta expresión verdad pues en este
caso queremos que sea igual
a la segunda derivada de f sí déjenme
borrar esto en realidad queremos que sea
igual a la segunda derivada de f pero
primero con respecto de x y luego con
respecto de y por supuesto como siempre
evaluado en el punto x 0 10/0 verdad y
entonces pues de aquí tenemos algo
inmediato verdad porque entonces b tiene
que ser esta segunda derivada parcial
verdad aquí no tenemos que dividir ni
nada
me tendría que ser la segunda derivada
de f con respecto de x y luego con
respecto de y aunque ya sabemos que no
importa el orden en general verdad
entonces ya ya tenemos de terminada la
segunda constante que nos faltaba y
ahora necesitamos calcular quién tendría
que ser la constante c y el razón en el
razonamiento esencialmente es es
simétrico al primer caso de cuando
calcula vamos a lo único que vamos a
hacer es que primero derivamos con
respecto de ye y luego con respecto de
ella así que te voy a dejar esto como un
ejercicio sirve que que puedes
fortalecer tus tus técnicas para derivar
con respecto de iu y a lo que tienes que
llegar es que nuestra constante c es
igual a un medio de la segunda derivada
de f con respecto de ambas veces
evaluada en el punto x 0 10/0 muy bien
este es el valor que nos interesa así
que digamos cuando introduzcas estos
tres valores en nuestra fórmula de aquí
arribita que teníamos verdad en la
función para q cuando pongamos a b y c
como encontramos más
entonces tendremos ya bien determinada
en nuestra función q verdad entonces
tendremos por ejemplo aquí nuestra parte
constante luego tendremos los términos
lineales y finalmente concluimos con los
términos cuadráticas verdad que son 3 y
si quieres adentrarte un poco más en en
quizás en algunos ejemplos de cómo
encontrar estas aproximaciones tengo un
artículo de este tema pero cómo podemos
darnos cuenta la notación se puede
volver muy pesada por lo que quiero que
trates de regresar a la idea geométrica
si hacemos la aproximación cerca de un
punto específico la aproximación
cuadrática se ve como esta superficie
que que si la cortamos en cualquier
dirección se ve como una parábola y esto
nos da una buena aproximación de la
función original así que aunque haya
mucha fórmula digamos creo que creo que
la intuición final es la importante sólo
estamos buscando una superficie que
abrace muy bien a la gráfica bueno con
esto dicho nos vemos en el próximo vídeo